oh it's time for our scene and unseen
segment we revealed the stories behind
the headlines for that we turn to Fox
News contributor Raymond Arroyo all
right Raymond Biden did conclude this
trip abroad but as I did note earlier in
the angle it kind of looked like a major
trip up right I mean it was bad Laura
and the president seemed confused by
everything around him even a raised
stage in Vietnam was a source of
bewilderment he was kind of do I step up
do I move forward is it going to take
off but when he opened his mouth to
discuss the G20 he may as well have been
talking about the GI Bill and it was a
string of words that even seemed to
confuse the world leaders in attendance
look at these reactions and today I'm
proud to announce that we've finalized
historic agreement for a new India
middle east Europe economic Corridor
contributing to more stable more
prosperous Middle East and I
particularly want to thank Prime
Minister Modi in the Crown Prince of
Saudi Arabia Mohammed and solemn so
excuse me Muhammad Salam and the
president of underline and the European
commissions and since it's uh he's not
speaking today uh I wanted to or maybe
you're speaking today
I had a note he wasn't speaking anyway
I'm going to stop there
oh my Lord Laura the faces on some of
these world leaders they were they were
rolling their eyes they're looking away
like when is this going to end but you
know it projects a decrepit instability
coming from the United States that
should be the centerpiece of the G20
this is an embarrassment now Raymond
they were all thinking what time do
cocktail cocktails start even the even
the Saudis they're not supposed to drink
they're like we're taking up drinking
now because of this this isn't this bad
and as you covered earlier Laura his
handlers have taken to now just cutting
off the president of the United States
in public something I've never seen in
27 years of reporting and covering
politics but there's a new tactic
they've now adapted which I think they
borrowed from the Oscars listen closely
it wasn't confrontational at all thank
you everybody this ends account press
conference thanks everyone
thank you
[Music]
Laura
Brendan Fraser was treated with more
respect at the Academy Awards okay this
is a disgrace but it didn't end there
when Biden tried to engage a reporter
the band played on
and I've raised it with every person
I've met with thank you
[Music]
the band had the orders Laura just keep
playing Raymond who chose the music you
know we always said who's making the
decisions in the White House inquiry
minds want to know who actually went
with the slow-mo kind of maneuvo jazz
track
at least they could have got given him
something a little more peppy or you
know old man take a look at yourself
um something yeah you don't want him
running you don't want him bopping or
running away and while Joe Biden was
Prat falling through the G20 in Asia
Kamala Harris was his proxy at the 911
commemorations in lower Manhattan today
but how did the VP spend her weekend at
home Laura in the yard commemorating
hip-hop with a few Pals then she broke
out the hip-hop moves with her homies
[Music]
foreign you know okay there are some
moments that really shouldn't be
recorded Raymond I
actually say that that
says vice president she is she's not too
bad of a little kind of dancing in place
I mean that's the best thing she's done
for her entire vice presidency I got man
you got to have to be good at something
she's pretty good she got the rhythm
going that's not bad hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else